oh I get it
I just don't understand it
hey I'm red Muffler Man and uh I like
Kingdom Hearts like I really like
Kingdom Hearts I remember back when I
was around 14 I borrowed my little
cousin's PS2 for about two weeks just to
Blitz through the first game and bought
my own PS2 that year just to blast
through Kingdom Hearts 2. the combat the
characters the premise the story oh God
the story there was just this
wonderfully Charming mesh of concept
game design and aesthetic that just kept
me in in terms of formative experiences
in my life I would rank it up there with
discovering Street Fighter 4 the
premiere of Naruto and Toonami and the
untimely death of my father when I
turned eight I'll never forget that day
I mean how could I he bought me a copy
of Mario Party 2 that day but uh did you
know there was supposed to be a Kingdom
Hearts cartoon produced by Disney back
in 2003 because I didn't what I'm so
confused how did this happen Okay so
let's wind the clock back here a bit
over the years the existence of a
Kingdom Hearts cartoon was somewhat of
an urban legend it was something that
had been rumored but all in all there
was no definitive evidence that it ever
existed nothing but Whispers In The Wind
a single Speck of sand in the great
desert that is tetsuya nomura's mind
Palace never to be witnessed by mortal
men
but wait look in the sky it's a bird
it's a plane it's Seth Kearsley the
director of Eight Crazy Nights so back
in September of 2022 Seth posted a
Twitter thread going over the details of
how he had been hired to direct the
pilot episode for a Kingdom Hearts
cartoon series essentially Seth after
his work on Eight Crazy Nights was
getting interview after interview
expressing how much he had wanted to
work on a show akin to an American anime
because directors on anime tend to have
a lot more creative freedom to tell the
stories they want to tell in comparison
to the Western animation industry at the
time Seth gets into contact with his
agent who tells him that Disney was
looking to bring on a director to get a
Kingdom Hearts TV show off the ground
Seth had a meeting with Disney they gave
Seth a copy of Kingdom Hearts 1 and then
he blitzes through the entire game in a
week and decides you know what the sword
gets pretty cool I'm in soon after
Disney showed set the script of the
Kingdom Hearts pilot and to quote Seth
after finishing the game I read the
script for the pilot it read like an
episode of Aladdin co-star the
characters from Kingdom Hearts I told
them I wanted to rewrite the script to
put the Kingdom Hearts characters at the
center of the story I was fired wow
Disney meddling with Kingdom Hearts to
force the main cast to take a backseat
see a focus on selling you on their
films
who could ever have foreseen this so
yeah Seth was fired but he really wanted
to work on Kingdom Hearts so he went to
the head of the studio and pled his case
and it turns out the head of the studio
was the guy who would pitch the idea for
the cage cartoon in the first place and
so Seth was rehired and he got to react
script to be much closer to the show
that he wanted to make and so with the
project greenlit Seth got to work on
boarding the pilot for Kingdom Hearts
Seth remarks during the production that
he took a good amount of inspiration
from Cowboy Bebop at the time wanting to
get across the same feeling of
loneliness spike in the crew had while
drifting through space as Sora would be
traversing from world to world with the
crushing Solitude of not being able to
find his friends Seth did The Impossible
he made the gummy ship from Kingdom
Hearts 1 interesting but Seth also
comments on a whole host of other
problems during production including
Disney not allowing the pilot to act as
An Origin episode so Seth had to cram
the origin of Sora and the Gang
alongside the plot of an already
existing episode in 11 short minutes and
then when he finished the storyboards he
handed them off to his video editor who
was supposed to make an animatic but it
turns out the editor didn't actually
know how to edit so Seth had to
basically draw edit and composite an
entire 11 minute episode of a television
show by himself I don't think I need to
explain how insane that is okay so
between getting fired unfired an entire
scriptery ride ridiculous stipulations
from Disney Executives and incompetent
staff Seth managed to finally complete
the pilot animatic and uh he kind of
killed it according to the early test
screenings for the show done by Disney
Kingdom Hearts had outperformed
literally every other pilot they had
screened in that period by a long shot
everyone loved it the show quickly
entered production and wait what what
what
what do you mean they just canned it so
uh yeah despite an incredibly positive
reception outperforming literally every
other pilot Disney decided they were
just gonna shelf Kingdom Hearts because
they didn't want to get in the way of
the games Seth was in his own words
crushed it was like winning and having
the trophy given to second place and so
the project laid dormant nothing more
than a videotape and an envelope of
storyboard sitting on a shelf in Seth's
office now fast forward back to 2022 and
suddenly Seth got hit by a car in a
video going on Seth's YouTube channel
talking about the pilot he recounts the
story of how he nearly died in a car
accident back in January fractured ribs
hips right pelvis lacerated heart
collapsed long ruptured spleen oh oh God
you get the idea but it put things into
perspective for him in his own words I
almost died and there's some [ __ ] I want
to put out in the world that almost
never got put out into the world and in
that same video Seth announced that he
was going to be releasing the Kingdom
Hearts pilot okay
um that's honestly really heavy I'm not
gonna make a joker or anything here like
honestly before writing this video I
always really liked Eight Crazy Nights
but I had no idea who Seth Kearsley was
until doing my research for this video
and uh I found out he uh also did a lot
of work on uh the Looney Tunes Show
which I think is one of the best
cartoons ever made and uh man Seth is
this amazing dude you should go follow
him on YouTube and Seth if you somehow
ever see this I'd love to buy you a
drink from one artist to another thank
you and so on October 11th 2022 almost
20 years after it was first produced
Seth released the pilot for Kingdom
Hearts on his YouTube channel is uh what
I would say but literally in the middle
of editing this video Disney took the
pilot down from Seth's Channel no yeah
uh we can't have nice things I guess uh
so uh no yeah uh back to the video but
as for the episode itself I absolutely
love it it does a great job of staying
faithful to the look and feel of the
original Kingdom Hearts the artwork is
surprisingly polished for an animatic
maid essentially by one guy and then
there's some scenes where their
roughness genuinely brought me to tears
with how much I was gackling like
look at this big on I am more than
[Music]
that it's so interrupt
and then there's Riku Riku is an [ __ ]
and I love it look at this [ __ ] eating
grin he literally spends the entire
episode just gaslighting Sora and acting
like a gigantic piece of [ __ ] which to
be fair is pretty on brand for Kingdom
Hearts 1 Riku but yeah this pilot is
amazing they even managed to get the
original voice cast to reprise their
roles from Kingdom Hearts 1 with the
sole exception being Sora due to Haley
Joel Osment not being available during
the time of recording looking back on
this pilot this time capsule of
Animation from the early 2000s it
honestly makes me sad that Disney passed
on this at the time of me writing this
video Disney has teased a Kingdom Hearts
show that'll be airing on Disney plus
and while I am hopeful for that it still
[ __ ] sucks that Seth's version with
all of his passion ended up getting
buried by the whim of Executives but at
the same time I'm grateful that Seth
finally released it after all these
years a pilot brought to light for a
show that never was but that's enough
for handling anime thank you all so much
for watching this video I really
appreciate it as per usual if you like
what we do feel free to drop a like
comment and hit that subscribe button
and if you like me you can follow me on
Twitch Twitter and YouTube at Red
Muffler Man and uh yeah have a good one
everybody take it easy